why do you see under arrest
[Applause]
can I ask you something what took you so
long to respond to me I don't feel like
being alone not tonight
she turns a tender I made you pick me I
liked your picture you have this sad
look on your face I felt sorry for you
thank you made a playlist that's the key
one going through my phone so what
happens to me
you're gonna drop me off and then you'll
go home I guess oh did you think we were
gonna have sex you failed to execute a
turn signal back there oh my bad step
out of the vehicle can I ask why officer
no you may not
J'son head going round now are you
serious
why the guy wanted me to die messed up
he's playing I don't think that's what
he wanted hey is this y'all we have to
go now it's all over the news
I support what y'all doing it was
self-defense in the black money Clara
when the police we have had in plain
sight you ladies I don't know yet
where were you safe here
it's an honor to meet y'all yeah I
really gave us on the believe oh I'm
tired of playing the scene
on the right of that as long as my lady
remembers be silent
it's all I need
thank you for this journey no matter how
it is
[Music]
you